we are loving native's new Limited
Edition Candy Shop collection right now
go to nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or use
promo code trash Tuesday at checkout to
get a sweet 20 off your first order
that's
nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or use promo
code trash Tuesday at checkout for 20
off your first order
hi slugs I'm doing stand up and I'm
coming to Miami and Atlanta and Raleigh
get tickets at Esther andice.com hey
sluggies I miss you this week you can
see me next in Toronto Canada at the
comedy bar April 21st and 22nd I'll be
in Raleigh back in North Carolina May
12th and 13th I will be in Baltimore at
magoobies I have been dying to get to
Baltimore
June 2nd and 3rd I will then be in Salt
Lake City Utah at Wise Guys June 9th and
10th and then also Calgary for The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival with Andrew
Schultz alright I love you guys I'll see
you soon Jamara did try to untie my
shoelaces I did and I did feel flirted
with for a hot second there I'm rooting
for a threesome
I really mostly want to be the spectator
yeah
the podcast started yeah oh
foreign
[Music]
oh wait what does it say
ring for [__] yeah
somebody gave after me
who huh who gave it to you for my
birthday and I was like I was um was it
from a person who gives you a BJ
yeah
Jamar you are very and I mean this now
I'm giving it to y'all
I mean you can't actually have that with
no judgments you are one of the horniest
people on Instagram that I and my feed
oh yeah you know why because because
people don't because people don't people
don't be acting horny on on on the
ground so I'd be like all right then
I'll just be that person I kind of
respect it because I'm like okay jamar's
like in character like he's being
himself he's honest you're you get what
you see is what you get you're a horny
guy
but not really no no when I be alone I
just be drawing
[Laughter]
like I don't I don't be I don't be
[__] like that you made this amazing
thing of Bobby that I
I don't even know what to call it did
you just ring Matt
[Laughter]
what the [__] it's so awkward in here
like what is gonna happen well she gonna
give me a Trouble Man she's already not
can't go back on tigerbelly
wait you're saying you can't come
back wait is that why you gave Bobby
that gift no no no no I was just making
[__] that was an incredible thing I what
do you call that it's almost like a it
was like this 3D thing of Bobby but he
had clothing options that you could
stick on his body it was like a Barbie
it was like a Barbie doll but a Barbie
doll and I hadn't it was like a
life-size Bobby
and I made it because I was just I was
in an art
you know thing and then so I made one of
Bobby Lee and it was just like a yeah
that thing right there
you could switch out yeah like on the
side well it's not on there but you can
switch out his clothing yeah he had a
little voice thing that's so cool of his
jokes and [__] if you press that thing
yeah and then he has a little
accessories over there I think I'm going
to it oh but it's also a light you're
talented oh for sure
100 okay I this is like the most I hate
when people do this on podcasts but I
haven't seen you in a while and I've
known you for so long I just can't stop
myself from asking what do you remember
about me in the early days when we met
I feel like I feel like I remember you
uh trying to spit in somebody's mouth
she used to try to like spit in people's
mouth like or or it was a one person she
kept on begging to uh who was who was
that I remember that because I know you
got it from Don I think and then I think
you start trying to do it to somebody
who was that
well I don't remember but I know you're
right but yeah that's right I'm like
come on let me spin in your mouth when I
feel like somebody let you do it and
then they said that your spit tastes
nasty or some [__] like that that's
probably the how my bad breath rumor
started because I was spitting in
people's mouths that [__] wait that that
is uh I can relate to that feeling of
wanting to spit in someone's mouth
because that's Bobby's first memory of
me he's spitting Bobby mouth y'all like
on first date or like the first time we
made out it was like our second date but
before we made up made out I was like
hey just let me spit in your mouth real
quick
and he was like what I was like open
your [__] mouth let me spit and he
let me I think it was me and Tony yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I totally forgot
about that we used to spit in each
other's mouths in front of people
yeah didn't he smoke cigarettes and [__]
he quit the year we were together I had
it like when I I had gotten a bank
account I got him off cigarettes but
then after they got them together yeah
but he started smoking like the day we
broke up
he was heartbroken too no he wasn't yes
he was really not not not not like
visibly but like you could feel it oh my
God that's like that that was your boy
that's the best thing I've ever heard
what else do you remember okay
um
let me see because Jamar and I did open
mics together I also I mean I do know a
story which I'm so jealous of and that
you guys have kissed before for a scene
who Okay Jamar I never kissed you before
yes you did oh my mama I never did okay
let me remind you you know it's serious
if I put that [__] on my mama do you
remember we were doing a short film for
Lexi
and you walked me down the aisle and it
was not in the script but you like swung
me around and dipped me and gave me a
big kiss but it wasn't tongue I ain't
kissed you I swear to God I I ain't
gonna say I never kiss you I would never
ever kiss you but I'm just saying like
ah
did we
I do remember us I do remember uh I do
remember uh Lexi paying well I used to
work at Target and she wanted us to
shoot that short yeah or that whatever
the [__] that was yeah and then uh and I
wouldn't come in and she was like I'll
pay you whatever Target's gonna pay you
and I was like all right and I do
remember us all [__] being there it
was you Willie I did that yeah was we
like Hotel people or some [__] like that
was me you Benji yeah we were at the do
you remember we were at the hotel Cecil
which is like we're we're a famous man
in Koreatown downtown
it's famous literally like two years I
kissed you yeah what'd you think
okay let's okay like I can really
remember and this one I had a front
rotten tooth too
and you'll spit that was around your
spitting day so I
was combined was probably crazy I
remember being like I I really loved you
so much that I I was just like oh that
was fun you know it wasn't you were no
it's like you were creeping on me no
yeah well I mean not at all not even a
little nah cause you always look like a
little girl thank you
don't let me you kiss a little girl in
the scene
anyway but yeah but it was a friendly
kiss so yeah that happened jealous
I mean like just it's coming out of my
ears how jealous I am oh my god listen
Jamara I really do want to apologize
because I think that people kind of
um turn it into a thing um on tigerbelly
a couple episodes ago maybe like a year
ago I said that out of all the comics I
would have sex with
you know like you'd be like number one
on my list yeah um I don't know if that
got back to you people kept on tagging
me and people kept on tagging me and
saying [__] I'm about to like who
because I forgot your name right so I
was like I was like I was like who who
the [__] is kalilah
and it was like you know Bobby Lee's
girlfriend and I swear to God I was like
that Chinese [__] that's exactly what I
said you were talking about me not Bobby
uh yeah and I was like oh and I was like
um and I was like oh that's crazy people
and then I think you guys said it again
on like uh
Theo Vons podcast or something like that
and so it kept on coming back so I was
up there like I was like wow she's just
talking [__] whatever and then I was
like hmm and then I uh and I went to
your page and I was just like
I was like yeah she all right I said
that's Bobby Lee's girlfriend I love
Bobby Lee so much
it would be like crazy right you know
but I really do like that you thought I
was a Chinese [__]
Chinese because whatever I really am
just very profoundly appreciative that
you said that you weren't attracted to
me because I looked like a little girl
what are you into I don't know I just
like as long as you're biologically a
woman and you pretty
[Laughter]
Maybe
you walked in here and you said I never
change yeah but but now as I'm watching
you like a little bit more and more I'm
over here like oh yeah yeah yeah
you see an adult finally hey I saw you
in Home Alone three or four oh yeah yeah
oh yeah I think you some yeah you told
me that yeah uh what kind of chicks am I
into yeah I don't know just be cute
are you in a relationship now
I don't think so situationship
I don't know I don't think so if you
don't think so you're definitely not
that's not true oh yeah you're right
there might be some out there that
thinks they are is there someone out
there that thinks they're your
girlfriend nah no not really
um I skipped Valentine's just to make
sure like just to make sure like uh this
this person knew their place how do you
skip Valentine's you just sleep the
whole day I just yeah I put my own
airplane on it and I just drew I just
drew all day where did you get your
shirt and can I buy it off of you I got
if the sleeves are cut off that's what I
that's she's trying to get you to take
your shirt off right now uh I got it
from Target
but you put the rip on yeah because
Cartoon Network is dead right right but
that's can I see it is it the cow is it
Cow and Chicken Johnny Bravo yes look
you gotta wash it though and it's kind
of dingy you still want it I I would
love it yeah man it worked after one of
the smartest people I I've ever met in
my damn life you know yeah man I am
Angela remember Angelo yeah remember
Angelo bro it's Angelo Bowers yeah did
you know Angela I didn't but Bobby told
me everything about him yeah we thought
he I mean because he was like one of the
first like ones that was like oh [__]
this dude gonna make it like yeah like
he's one of the funniest people to ever
[__] live like writers like
rider-wise he's just grave like he's
like I'll be back I'm just gonna put it
on okay yeah like like he was just
[__] phenomenal dude like um yeah I'd
still be missing him now I'm in here I'm
[__] wife beater and [__]
I think it works wait you're very strong
oh yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna stay like
this
I didn't really you didn't realize I was
buff you know I was buff right oh yeah
yeah oh yeah
I've uh never really been this close to
a man so buff before yeah
yeah you good
well women nah women are strong too
though you ever been hit by a woman no
you never been here have you ever been
hit by a woman oh [__] yeah I used to be
a scrapper women are hard yeah women hit
hard I think I hit really hard yeah my
sister hits really hard but then no I
went to um I got into a lot of fights in
high school and a lot of fights like
maybe like my freshman year of college
which is with dumb [__] but I was a
dumb [__] too though yeah yeah women
women fight hard yeah what's up with you
Ashley you got a boyfriend yeah for real
you married I what you married you got a
boy no I'm not married why I'm married
and I have a boyfriend No I um I'm
engaged but he's out of town oh okay
ring the bell ring the bell [__] where's
my bell Esther Jamar you would not like
me sexually I am why first of all you be
crying and [__] no no I cry I'm the
crier but not during after it's like
when I after I come then I don't but
it's not emotions it's just like the
tears just come out I want to know what
are you like in bed like because I a
beast what do you mean what's a beast
like Beast
explain
say more
do you go down on girls
yeah I do I do you hesitated no I really
do I used to have I used to have this
girl who I didn't even used to have sex
with I used to just go and just eat her
out oh you're a pleasure Dom yeah I used
to do that you read like one and then
what will you just leave yeah and I'll
just leave oh that's that's what I
picked up on and okay so because your
bell says ring for blow job I I'm just
curious like what would happen between
us because I I get a lot of feedback
that I'm not good at blow jobs yeah you
seem like bitey
laughs
is anyone really exciting it yes they
call them Jimmy Jaws how does I know
that my teeth don't belong there I know
that there are girls who are just a
predisposed I think to dragging their
teeth they're the same people who clang
on their spoons when they eat so you can
always know who a Jimmy Jaws is when you
see him eat because they clink it hits
the back of their teeth and that could
just be an anatomical problem okay I'ma
start paying attention to how people eat
what they spoons I am not teeth teeth
oriented
I am curious I now have a follow-up
question why would teeth be bad
oh some dudes like it like Teeth seems
like like if you go like this
that feels good you are a bitey [__]
would that be bad
some some girls have used the teeth good
but like most like mostly all I could be
y'all be doing it by accident that
should be scraping my [__] up
I can't [__] for two weeks what would
you do in a situation where like you're
into the sex but the blow job is bad
like what would you do would you just
make it stop would you give tips if it
was bad yeah
um
yeah I just I just I just like tap her
head like
and then just go like that you take her
off yeah
[Music]
native deodorant checks a lot of boxes
it has 72 hour odor protection naturally
derived ingredients in a smooth
residue-free application native also
offers a variety of scents with new and
limited edition since being released all
the time when you use native you will
smell amazing all day long thanks to
their long lasting scents I love The
Limited Edition Candy Shop collection
the gummy bears and strawberry vanilla
are my absolute favorite sometimes I'll
throw a little sour Berry belt under my
arms when I go to the movies so I can
match the smell of my
delicious Sour Patch Kids
now is the time to make the switch from
antiperspirant to Native when you visit
their site you can discover all their
fresh scents and maybe even try out one
of their body washes while you're at it
right now go to nativedeo.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
at checkout to get a sweet 20 off your
first order that's
nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or use promo
code trash Tuesday at checkout for 20
off your first order
foreign
what's your finishing move finishing
move yeah I mean what's your you know
um you know Mortal Kombat there's a
moment there when the two fighters are
like fatality what's your what's your
final thing what's your favorite what's
your um how do I say like is there a
dance term where you're like that is her
thing like that move is her thing
signature move I don't think I have a
signature move now that I think about it
do you have one
um
I think I'm a pretty like all-around
athlete
like I can do things not I'm not the
best at everything but I can do them all
like decently
what kind of what's a good signature
move you've experienced from a woman
check skin I like I like when a chick
like right
and then her ass is just going like
oh yeah see I think I know what you're
talking I think that's interesting kind
of right but then what I like to do is
this right I hold your ass when I go
over here like this and then I
do it I like bounce fish like a
basketball
that is really you're you actually are
really like you look like you're
classically trained but I'm not but but
somebody but you don't I don't think I
[__] every girl like the same way though
like either yeah like some girls like
I've been bad at like some girls like
girl like
maybe like three months in that three
months ago and she may be coming like
under a minute like she was just too
much
body body
ass jiggling in my it was too much she
wasn't a stripper she wasn't a stripper
from the hood but like I mean she had
her body her her delivery had that
personality on it that [__] cooked me
bad I just try to interrupt every now
and then she don't know she was like
what
I want Vengeance but I don't know how to
but I'll I don't I want to rematch
I got I got a blue pill now I'm ready to
[__] kill this [__] you know there
are also those um they used to be our
sponsors but the Roman swipes what is it
where it's like this thing you can swipe
on your dick to last a little bit longer
because you have a formidable opponent
like that [__] you know had you in
under a minute right she probably walked
away like that's a two-pump Chomp yeah
so you want Vengeance but you got to
come with a pill and the Roman swipes I
think
and you got to get one out the tank
before the rematch
I didn't know that I was gonna I don't
know I didn't even know I was gonna have
sex with this person and it just
happened do you have like soft Christian
love making sex like ever do you ever
like gaze into a girl's eyes and you're
just so locked in and it's sweet and you
don't do anything but missionary
but it still feels good and you like
being there it's not like the bouncing
basket you know what I mean you're not
bouncing anyone's ass yeah yeah yeah
every now and then
every now and then I'll do that you see
me but that's what I do like when I'm
when I'm resting when I'm resting I'm
taking a break I just get a missionary
that I just kind of just kind of you
know wind my hips like a dirty [__]
I feel like you're arresting sex is like
my wild sex what yeah what are you
talking about
I don't know it's like I didn't you like
slow sensual no I think though that when
you're biting
no I don't think so are you into biting
sometimes sometimes it's by too hard
yeah you know but yeah a little bit
though I ain't bit nobody in a while
because my I chipped my tooth like like
a month ago
so I am I've been holding off on the
biting because that [__] can really [__]
you up you and I have that in common we
have yeah no it just gaps
Gap yeah but now I gotta I got a tip too
on the Gap so I'm scraping [__]
I feel like you guys both sort of
insinuated that sex can be like
competitive with the partner which that
I have to say like really freaks me out
I view it as like we're on the same team
like this is a beautiful yes it can be
that too okay Jamar I wanted to ask you
as someone who is just gotten out as
someone who has just gotten out of a
10-year relationship
um what are your what is your advice on
me getting back out there and [__]
again
um because I'm weird I can't just like
meet a dude and then [__] them that
night like it's got there's got to be a
what's what's uh what's holding you back
from is there anybody that you're
interested in and and like do you like
do you actually want to actually like
get [__]
like we're talking about
um I think that
um I
well I don't know I just yeah I think
it's a mental thing like I have to sort
of like like you as a person before
[__] do you do you have to like the
person or you can just go go for it I
kind of have to like the person yeah
yeah
and so for me I have to kind of like I
guess like respect I have to respect you
know there's like a mutual respect and
trust and then like we can go hard after
but without that I'm just not down oh
yeah and so you haven't found that
um here and there sprinkling of it
but yeah so how long do you think I
should wait before entering another
relationship
how long you been broken up a year
really
wow just not publicly though oh yeah
that's right yeah
um you can you can go now
yeah you think so I mean why wait
another year
I mean you can go now
that that's long enough it's long enough
yeah what's your what's your what's your
what's your uh what's your guy like
um
he's smart and funny
and nice to me
why
okay
okay like you know see Alpha
uh in his in certain ways with me yeah I
would say Dave is like the truest Alpha
he's like he's like he doesn't need to
show his power he just is powerful but
he never needs to kind of bro out with
anyone yeah okay that's actually a good
call it's like how do you
detect if someone is truly an alpha like
I'm struggling with that in life and I'm
also
like
what qualities do you have that are
feminine or masculine that you
lean into I don't know like
I guess I just sometimes I think certain
people are alphas because of the ways
that they act and present themselves and
then I have I'm like wait that's not it
at all the presentation has nothing to
do with whether or not you're an alpha
okay so that's huge and also I don't
want to date an alpha bro like I want to
bait a [__] like I want someone who's
not gonna try to well that's not true
I want Alpha in its true a sense which
is just securely attached it doesn't
need to be boastful about it knows it
and
isn't a quiet quiet about his power
like that to me is like the truest Alpha
because if you're a person who
constantly needs to say you're an alpha
you're the most beta in the room right
but also Alpha give who gives a [__]
like if he's a good dude if he's a
little insecure why the [__] not okay
also
I used to always think like oh I'm
submissive in the bedroom but then I'm
like wait no I think I'm like a mix of
both do you feel like you guys are a mix
of both too it depends on my mood yeah
mix of both yeah sometimes it's just
nice to receive other times it's nice to
like be a full participant and like I
told you like I wanted to be like a
pillow princess because like I did most
of the work when I was with Bobby like I
always I did the initiation I was the
one who did you know like he had like he
just he he's 51 he got tired a lot so
like I would always be on top things
like that also we couldn't do doggy
because just like the height you know
disparity there so you have to put like
phone books on his knees or like wear
platform heels talking about because
Bobby and I can't do doggy I'm five
eight he's like five three I can't
either
what right yeah because I'm not tall
enough the height is is is everything I
think when it comes to Doggy you ever do
doggy with a chick and she got a pointy
ass and that [__] be [__] up your
pelvis
yeah [__] yeah does that take you out
of it that [__] just hurts what is it I
feel like I'm getting sock in my pelvis
like a pointy ass is just a bony butt oh
yeah if you don't have a lot of like the
home set
he bit this girl over and her ass looked
like two elbows
he does like Hades joke or whatever but
that's funny yeah yeah
oh boy you ever hit that you ever hit
some [__] like that no no not you like
there are no men here yeah that's crazy
though phone books is that was that I
don't want I don't want to eat too bad
no but then what I was saying was
because
um I had done so much of the work for 10
years I was telling Esther I was like oh
I'm entering my pillow princess era I'm
just gonna lay back and now just receive
that's all I want to do but then I tried
that and I didn't have as much fun I was
like no I want to participate like it I
get off on being like an active
participant in bed I cannot be a pillow
princess I'm 38.
my pussy's about to dry up no no
actually you about to because you're
about to be 40 like you're about to go
real hard you think so I feel like you
are you know what that's a good point
like I've never been hornier than
um I have been I've never been hornier
than I am now not right now right now
but
um no she well oh no no no oh my bad my
bad well maybe you have yeah uh uh
recently or whatever or I don't I don't
know but like 40s like I mean like right
around yeah you ever been with an older
lady
how much older than you but I was like
I was in college like this lady was
I was 21 and she was
32. oh
and so also
I was 24 in this lady was
like 45 but not like dumb oh yo
say it say it
um I didn't I didn't [__] this lady but
I ran into a lady in erwan and and she
was like older she was like 70 she was
probably 70 but she looked but you could
tell she was like she could tell she was
like a Playboy model like back in her
days right and I was like I was looking
at her actually she was she was looking
at me and I was like hi and then she was
like hi and then um I said hey you're
you're pretty I like your smile and then
she goes uh she goes thank you she goes
uh she goes you look great too and I go
I go thank you and I go um do you talk
to black dudes that's what I said and
then she was at the like as a matter of
fact I do
70 year old lady I said oh okay that's
it I feel like I feel like we should
exchange though oh so you guys exchange
numbers things numbers right so there's
more oh my God I love you keep going so
this girl so this lady uh I was like yo
I said I started Googling her or
whatever right
uh I ain't gonna say like exactly who
she is but she's like kind of like when
she was somebody back in the days and
then so I was like oh okay so I said hey
and I said I finally text her I said I
said hey we should hang out and she goes
oh of course you know and she's 70 and I
thought she thought she already got the
grandma boys Loki like it's crazy but
anyway this lady she lives in she lived
in the Hollywood Hills very [__] nice
house in the Hollywood Hills like so
I I took a uber I took an Uber there I
was like oh all right nighttime daytime
nighttime okay right and it was in the
Hills like the Hollywood Hills so it's
like she lived in a place where it's
like okay here's a gate and then you
have to walk half a mile to get to her
house like a compound yeah yeah yeah
yeah but but it was so [__] dark it
was so [__] dark I was like oh my God
I'm gonna get eaten by a [__] coyote
a little [__] [__]
so I was so I had all my light or
whatever my little iPhone light and I
would I was at the light I was like hey
I go are you around here
and then she was like why is she like
Stephanie she was hitting like oh my God
that light is so bright she was like and
I was like where are you she was like
cut the light off and I'll reveal myself
I swear to God and I was like uh I was
like uh all right and cut the light off
and uh and all of a sudden I put this on
my mama she appeared and she appears
this house she appeared with a red light
it was like a red light and it was like
a black like silhouette of this old
[__] you know she was like I'm right
here
and I was like oh [__] okay all right
just start walking I felt like Hansel
and Gretel bro
[Laughter]
I was like walking up I was like walking
up and I was like oh hey and then she
was just like my my that they make those
iPhone lights so bright
I feel like I've literally said that on
a date before it was me every time every
time every time we do an activity she
would just show her age like more and
more right wait how you hung out more
than once no no okay okay
all the times we uh we were like the
whole time we were hanging out she would
just show her age more and more okay so
what happened like I want to know how
that night yeah so we go in I was like
all right you know
in her house it was filled with this
whole [__] red light like all this
[__] red lightning [__] she wouldn't
like kinky like this right kinky no the
[__] was 70. so like the lights was
sensitive to her eyes
so I was like so I was like I was like
oh I said yeah I said whatever I said
yeah so uh so what do you do all day you
know I took off my jacket like this or
whatever yeah she was like oh the guy
just um I just hula hoop what it's on my
[__] life no I mean she's like
would you like the hula hoop
[Laughter]
hula hoop s
she said what did you come here today
uh you know just hang
you know she was like okay well we can
start by hula hooping I was like [__]
fine
[Laughter]
I'm sorry hula hooping [__] like that
she was like man I must worry I'm not
that good at this
I was like all right all right damn the
hula hoop
so I said [__] this hello I said what
else do you do
she goes oh she goes wow I also play
catch
and I was at the like play catch Oh Lady
it's nine o'clock at night I say what
the [__] are you trying to do
he was looking like I hate you know I
just like oh she's like would you like
to play ping pong and I was like all
right
long story short long story short this
[__] really just want the hula hoop
ping pong and I ain't got no [__]
but you went in one of you trying to get
that yeah but I didn't want to I don't
and as of low-key as I was looking at
her like when she was like hula hooping
and [__] whatever and just send me of
his body I said I was looking at her and
I said man Jamaria be wrong you would be
wrong because I was gonna try to beat
that [__] up
beating that [__] up I was looking at
her body I said you [__] up if you do
that oh my God you could hurt her yeah
fragile ribs fragile bones like you
could get if you also like the statistic
is if you're an elderly person and you
break a hip like the likelihood of you
dying in the next like one to two years
is really high yeah so I didn't want to
be that guy that breaks the hip you
don't want to break the hip are you so
you were into her though you were
attracted to her
if we're a 70 year old old school
Playboy model like she I was like I was
like
you know yeah yeah no I mean probably a
lot of it yeah I mean how much of it was
like the idea that oh this is novel I
can talk about this but also like damn
she's hot or like she's
it wasn't really about the story to me I
was like I was like oh she's kind of
cute like to be an owner like to be an
older lady yeah you know like she was 70
but she kind of took care of herself so
I mean she actually did really she was
actually in the wellness I'm like all
that [__] so she like really took care
of herself but like he was still 70 like
once I saw her body and all that [__]
like like just in clothes and like hula
hooping and [__] and I was like
I maybe if you had just stuck around
longer she you know after the eighth
activity maybe she would have no she
said she said I gotta go to bed at 10
o'clock yeah you got there at nine and
her bedtime was at 10. that's pretty
late for an elderly lady I think and she
lived there by herself thank you I mean
that's a really hot story I was really
hoping you guys were gonna
[Music]
Iron Man when I was like dude I used to
live in Iceland Baldwin Hills I'm from
here like when I really just living like
Baldwin Hills and um
there was like this lady there was like
these lady this lady who used to live
downstairs in the art they were our
friends his mom
and um but she was like she was thick
than a [__] like thick like uh
she wasn't a crackhead
but if she she was just thick and she
yeah like she wore a short shorts ass
hanging out all kind of [__] right and
so uh so one day and so uh one day we
went to the ice cream truck right
around the corner we had to run and [__]
so I was like that oh [__] I'm gonna go
catch that ice cream truck the lady uh
the mom was up there like oh I'm gonna
come with you I'm like I'm like 13 and
I'm like and I'm like oh yeah hell yeah
the ice cream truck around the corner
you like ran with me and all that [__]
and she was like yeah it was an ice
cream truck and she was like uh she was
like damn I like your lips and I also
feel like it goes up to like
that was it
how did I make you feel I I wish I
wasn't a little [__] back then because
I would have for sure I would have for
sure I would have for sure ate that
crackhead [__] up
for sure wait how old how old were you
were you already [__] at 13. no no I
didn't remember until I was 20. 20. yeah
yeah I was like uh yeah I was like a
late bloomer for sure but like did you
have
um [__] before 20 did you do other
stuff make out with girls
he I went to a I went to like uh I don't
know it's like some some like awkward uh
some awkward phase right it wasn't in
the I was in I thought women were
beautiful and great but I wasn't like
focused on that [__] or whatever until I
got around friends who are focused on it
so
um I wasn't I didn't get like sexually
active active active until I was like 18
and then I was with a girl for like five
years and then but she was a virgin and
so we were both virgins wait till we get
married and like all this stuff and I
was down for it or whatever and then
like we broke up uh I lost my virginity
to some chick and then she lost her
virginity to a a tow truck drivers
that oh God so I didn't get really
sexually active until I was like like 20
and but like crazy crazy crazy like 24
yeah I wish I had waited a little longer
like
I was the first time I was 15 but then I
waited a whole year again before having
sex because I just felt so like I was
not ready I my body was like tensed up
it hurt me and I immediately felt the
ick after like I am breaking up with him
immediately and this was my boyfriend
and I mean like I don't want to ever see
you again that's how I knew I wasn't
ready and then I waited till my next
boyfriend just like a whole year after
that I was 15 too yeah yeah
[Laughter]
and I didn't even
damn I didn't even when I'm thinking
about it I'm like damn I didn't catch a
I didn't even guess what channel 20 is a
great age though because there is some
you know what I mean like I started late
in fact for because my homies like
Autumn Foods they lost everything it was
like 13 14 15 like you know like and I
didn't they weren't my friends back then
but like the friends I ended up making
in high school and then I think when I
was 17
I had went to like this camp or whatever
and there's this girl there I I like I
like finger banged her and all that [__]
I remember that [__] too because I went
back to my I went back to my uh my 10 or
whatever and I fell asleep just like
this like
[Laughter]
foreign
that's so sweet
it was cool I think sexual things can be
funny I get I'm like giggly during sex
like I like to be silly but I've noticed
that
that's not really received that one it's
not a turn-on for me if a guy is coming
in and he's trying to like poke me or
touch me in like a jokey way I'm out it
completely just dries up the [__] so
fast like he's got to come in with like
the look of [__] like hunger or the
feeling of hunger or else if he's trying
to make something funny I'm out
yeah just during sex we can be funny the
other 23 and a half hours of the day now
I'm really wondering like is did we
lose our virginities too young I've
always been
like I've always thought that was a good
thing to just like get it out of the way
and have the experience but then you say
20 is good
I don't I don't know I'm just we all
develop at different like rates I think
but I know for myself like I didn't get
any education on it like I didn't know
what the [__] I was doing I was probably
Jimmy Jaws for like the first five years
of my life you know like I probably you
know scraped a couple dicks
you know in my teenage here I don't
understand it's like guys want
to like have you grab it and like do
stuff but a little teeth and that's the
problem yeah because you could uh you
that [__] like it just burned like it
just burned like after you scrape that
[__] because now it's like raw meat it's
like you you scrape that [__] to like
the white meat and even just a little
even just a little scrape like if you
get hot it's sometimes you can't get as
hard as you can or whatever like
afterwards and all that [__] because
when they get hard or whatever that
[__] start to hurt because now
it's expanding and [__] and now I'm
exposing the customer I gotta go put
some colloidal silver on that
[__] and heal that [__] up fast
so I can [__] this chicken three days
[Laughter]
what were your childhood pastimes Jamar
uh
man I used to steal a lot
I remember that wait me too bro oh my
God Halle I I used to have wire cutters
in my purse so as my sister my best
friend and I and she was a small Asian
girl so we would always kind of send her
out and go through Sephora because like
no one ever suspected her because she
was just so innocent looking but we
would go into like all of these stores
and just cut the tags off because this
is in high school this is when I wanted
like like the certain jackets that I
could never afford like the Rocawear
jackets the echo the baby fats I just
went on a tear through that mall
what did you steal
um
when I stole I was like a kid kid I was
like
I started still at six what would you
steal
um I remember I jacked a lady I jacked a
lady in her family what
I'm not laughing at your hunger it's
just is she just funny she just sent me
out to play and I'm like I'm gonna play
I get a [__] energy [__]
so I was so [__] hungry and [__] when
she um she had like she'll make her stay
outside all day and I'm like [__] man
I'm hungry and so uh they had just built
this McDonald's and I saw like this uh
this Mexican family uh by this big ass
come out with these big ass [__] bags
and [__] and I was at the like oh
hell yeah and I ran I remember running
so [__] fast I run so [__] fast
towards like a Mexican lady he had like
three she had like three kids and I was
like
and I had him back I was running with
the bags like this fries and [__] was uh
slamming out I mean falling out of the
goddamn uh bag and [__] my Hopper I
hopped the gate uh to like this
Elementary School
I was just [__] start eating that
[__] yep
so I jacked back
I go to the liquor store and steal some
Mexican bread oh yeah what's Mexican
bread it's the the Conchas the um yeah
so good the ampandulses the sweet breads
that's those right so good
and I should sell stupid [__] like we
had a parakeet and uh and so I went to
like Ralph's one time and I stole uh and
I stole like some bird seeds because I
was stealing from my cousin or whatever
because I wanted like kind of like I
don't know like be accepted or didn't
think that I was like cool or whatever
so I was like look man I got you
something you know what I'm saying like
it's for Chichi
that's so sweet
I had a parakeet named Courtney I named
her after Courtney Love in the 90s
and she would pick up my cuticles and
she would do everyone's Nails really
well because she just loved eating like
the cuticles but she was like free
roaming the bird you should just do
y'all now yeah really really cute and
then I later on I had a son Conyer and
this was like what's that it they kind
of look like parrots but they have like
a yellow head but this thing was so
smart no smaller than a cockatoo the
thing was so smart that it was potty
trained so you could just every like two
hours you'd be like go poopy over a
trash can and it would go poop and it
would cuddle with me and we would love
on each other did you have an emotional
connection with it it's like a dog
Esther because these birds are
flockbirds so they want to be close to
you they're so incredibly smart like my
next one and I'm not gonna steal one out
off of nature but if I I want to rescue
like a baby crow like crows to me are
the coolest things like ever Crow or
Raven or any corvid really would you
would it live in um a cage or a fruit no
no no free free
smart too Ravens are incredibly smart
they are the only like animals outside
of monkeys and humans who do who passed
a mirror test so they have a
self-awareness they're really like
complex with their tasks but they have
funerals too yeah and if you do them
wrong ones they'll remember your face so
distinctly that if you if they see you
again they'll come for you yeah so you
have to be nice to cross befriend them
those and tigers are bingeful
vengeful really vengeful and I don't
like the way like like how we've named
animals like crows I think a pack of
them are called like a murder of crows
and I'm like why those birds are [__]
dope they're so smart yeah and I think
that people are just threatened by
things that are like
Superior like we call them pests like
rats pigeons crows these animals that
are obviously so [__] Dopey and
cockroaches those are pests but they can
live without their heads for like 20
days they're obnoxious yeah because they
can compete with us that's why they
can't compete with us they be in your
food and [__] yeah if you live it if you
yeah I live in cockroaches my whole life
oh wait where are you from uh Chicago
too cold
too cold we had the the B-52 the bombers
the big ones that would fly into your
hair oh yeah those [__] were
scary the Philippines yeah
so if you are are you brave enough to
kill a cockroach yeah oh okay
did you ever used to like kill them like
creatively and [__] like kicks yes with
a with a magnifying glass oh yeah I
would get a tick and then I would wait
for them to explode yeah yeah isn't that
wait okay in your defense
I didn't I didn't know I needed
defending isn't that how you're supposed
to kill ticks like I feel like I've
heard the only way is you have to burn
them or they don't die uh no I think you
can put them in something like caustic
fluid I'm sure and they'll probably
drown and die okay but I don't know I
don't know you might be right alcohol
kills them instantly it says okay I
don't know what what are you afraid of
spiders bullfrogs I hate bullfrogs what
why are you afraid it was big they they
they slimy and they legs they're like
they're just so I hate that [__] I love
frogs and lizards I do too I can catch I
we used to catch toads I don't like I
don't mind frogs I don't like the big
ones the ones with a big the bullfrogs
they're like the size of like a head and
[__] like that I'm like I'm out
bullfrogs are pretty big but toads are
big too but they're like the size like
your fish you can I can grab those I'm
talking about huge ones like and they're
slimy and it's just like [__] that [__]
yeah I like frogs I am realizing like
our life experience is so different like
because you're buff as [__] like you
keep talking about my body
well let me continue
I'm like a small girl and I feel like
the whole world is scary to me like are
you can you just go anywhere at night
and not be scared yeah
because
remember to Citizen app yeah so uh it's
always like I live I live like Sunset
like La Brea like over there yeah and so
it's always [__] going on yeah
Cincinnati going off going off but I'll
be walking around and don't [__] be
happening to me and I'm like oh okay
because I'll be walking past sketchy
people all the time and I'm like like
heat yeah I go to 7 11 3 o'clock in the
morning
I don't be scared
yeah really cool I want that oh but
you're a girl though too also you're so
petite Esther and I'm a scaredy cat but
I think that's why I'm a scaredy cat
it's like women jog during the day and
they get murdered like it's just during
the day yeah that's crazy kill somebody
during the day
it's not like the bay
get that [__] at night
wear black like I don't know yeah I
think um I'm trying to see where I feel
yeah I'm kind of scared of everything
too I'm [__] scared of roaches bro I
mean yes because I live with them for
too long they're like it's like it's
like living with your abuser for a long
time and and then like taking a break
and then seeing them again and you're
like oh [__] you're back you know yeah
but then while you were in the abuse for
years like you kind of just got used to
it so it's not until you're out of it
that you start to fear them so I think
that's where my fear comes from what
else are you scared of I'm like very
curious now
uh oh [__] frogs no frogs spiders
I'm not crazy I'm not crazy uh scared of
them
um
I don't oh
a big ass praying mantis really you ever
see a bit not not a praying man is cool
but I've seen them big like and I've
seen using like North Carolina and they
look and they like really like I'm I'm
with Gerards from huh where'd your rods
from yeah my mama live out there now oh
okay so I want to go visit her and I saw
like these big ass like they're probably
like the size of this and it was like
climbing up a Walmart like like a
Walmart wall and I was like I I freak
out it's you know what's crazy about
praying mantis they always say like oh
the female you know you always hear like
the female will eat the male after sex
and then I was like that's not true
that's probably just something like
people made up so I found a female and I
took us the males are obviously smaller
and I put them in a jar and I swear to
you within that hour she gobbled his ass
and I was like oh [__] it's real what
they say it was so quick too like she
didn't even waste any time why'd she
kill him because I guess when she gets
the nut you know oh they [__] and then
killed him yeah she's like you're
useless to me
a dishy I think there's even a movie
called praying mantis that's about a
woman who like kills like men did that
thing but but that's like black what
black widows do that too do they is that
why they're called black widows black
widows oh
um they're guy afterwards they also um
apparently when they kill them they lay
twice as many eggs because of the acid
from the male once they consume the male
some sort of acid uh gets incorporated
into the legs eggs they lay that is so
cool so it makes for a better
you look inspired well I'm like is this
sort of the founding is this like the
origin story for why we live in a
patriarchy like men knew that like our
Instinct would be to kill them after sex
so they're like we have to like keep the
women down
you know what you know how like uh don't
win bees uh come they testicles explode
or like when they sting you they die I
know that but there's another one like
where they have testicles yeah I don't
know about those it's something I I read
so many animal facts somebody mixed them
up like but like some something like
that happens and then like you know how
like men like when we come like we like
go to sleep
it's like
that's just us is going dormant it's not
gonna be sleepy it's just like we ain't
got no more life force wait that happens
to me too I don't think it's just a man
thing because when I come like I wanna
I'm so tired I could not even care to
like wipe off any like come crust off of
me I could I could fall asleep with a
towel on my [__] and just like pass out
do you enjoy scraping to come off like
like like that like um like glue
I don't mind it yeah I think it's like a
activity yeah yeah it's an activity food
that's fun I have a I have a weird
question
if a white person is like way too
excited about black lives matter is that
a red flag I don't know I don't know I
don't I don't like it too much like I
mean I don't I don't hate it but I don't
it's just like when they a little bit
extra about it because it's like they
can't wait to show that they're not
racist it's like that's what it's coming
off to me and I don't think all white
people are racist but I'm like but if
somebody's super excited about it it's
like because they're super hyped to be
like yeah I racist oh man but I've been
living with the guilt of
they're just trying to you know shave
the white guilt a little bit and this is
yeah I do it why is that you no I I just
in my neighborhood like there's a lot of
people
that have signs that are like and white
silence and like like black lives matter
and
I sort of get the same I mean it's I get
the same feeling that you just described
where I'm like you guys are too it's
like too don't they call it virtue
signaling it's performative a little bit
too especially a lot of people like in
LA because aside from putting out signs
like what really like are they doing you
know right right like I saw that on like
a nice house and it was like
that's what you're doing to help but
also but also also it's kind of to keep
um
if there's ever a riot again you know
like they want to have that on there
she's like no we support what sport
please don't break our [__] you know
that's what it's for it's like a beware
of dog sign like
but for
Alm people
that's so interesting
um I I guess like
I this isn't this has nothing to do with
with that or sort of but like what I
find interesting is like when dudes like
find out that I am like Filipino like
from like there's a when I see them
getting excited over like
the fact that I am
like a [__] immigrant or Filipino
that kind of freaks me out when they
like Zone in on it what what is an
example of them zoning in like and you
know who you've heard of Asia files
right like Asia files are like the
George kimmels of the world which is
like they'll never admit it but they
only date Asian chicks yeah it's like
you can always tell you've never felt
that way have you ever been with like a
white girl who only like dates black
guys say for instance yeah and I've also
been like a I've also been like a white
girl's like first black dude and did
they always say it you're my they have
to announce it there's a thing yeah for
sure yeah I remember dating this um I
remember I used to date this one white
chick and she I think that she was
trying to do that where she was like
trying to curve her white get or her
racism by dating a black dude or
whatever and I go to her crib and uh
she'll have like pictures of uh Barack
Obama no oh God Michelle's books oh
Kendrick Lamar
right
just like this [__] like this is just
braces like he's just race braces
this is where I knew it was kind of
weird a few a few reasons like
she'll be she used to want me to read to
her right
so she's the one she used to want me to
read to her so I just be like all right
but she gave me a book I can read my ass
off like whatever but sometimes I [__]
up on some words right and so I'll be
like and so she could be like a she was
a hella reader she gave me like these
like these books or whatever and I'd be
like because the man would go down to
the shop and uh and I realized I was
like man is she probably thinks oh this
is like a slave like
like this feels like uh like a slave
like reading to me and I like this whole
theater of it all you know and it's just
just kind of hard
I don't give
up and then I I did not and then I um I
wrote a um it'll probably never see the
light today I wrote this movie called uh
not another slave movie
it I was like I was like yeah man it is
run time I was really going hard trying
to get this [__] made right it did so I
was like hey can you can you read my
script since you like to read so much
like
nobody wants to read like you know she
was like I actually like yeah she's like
I guess like what's it called like oh
it's called not in the slave movie and
it's like send me that now send me that
now say oh my God I can't wait to read
it or whatever like she couldn't wait to
read it or whatever she writing oh my
gosh the funniest movie I've ever read
in my life and I was like you're not
supposed to say that because like you
keep white like it was like I don't know
something that's I don't know but I saw
I did kind of feel that she was trying
to
um I I dated a white guy who was like
always really proud to announce that
he's only ever dated or [__] brown
girls and he felt that need to announce
it to me every time he's like it was
like a a badge a badge for him to be
like oh yeah I don't like white girls
like I only [__] like brown girls and
like the girl before me was like
Hawaiian and then there was like
Japanese and I'm just like that's
[__] a weird thing dude like he and I
think it's a kind of something similar
where it's just a notch for them another
thing to like you know and um it's it's
icky yeah I only dated in high school I
only dated black dudes and well my high
school is predominantly like black and
Latino but
um I didn't date a white boy until like
much later on where are you from
Philippines so I dated Asian dudes when
I was younger my very first boyfriend in
the Philippines he was the only black
guy in the entire Island in Cebu his
name was James Morris and boy was I in
love but then um you went to high school
out here though
um yeah I came here right when I um
ninth grade uh what high school did you
go to her um Blair High School in
Pasadena yeah yeah green and uh yellow
Vikings yeah yeah
on Marengo yeah yeah
um but yeah I never thought I would end
up with like
um when I did finally date a white guy I
was in a relationship it was like
it was with that guy who was always very
braggy about like don't worry I only
date brown girls and I'm like oh [__]
that's weird
[__] weird I was talking to myself my
sister started talking to me about that
because it's like they they think uh
they think I only date white girls is
that is that um the rumor around town
yeah and it's just like it's like that's
[__] crazy because it's like like
it's so not true and I said and then she
was like well how come how come I'll
never see you like with like a like a
black girl and I'm like man I'm like and
I'll be like man I [__] like two black
chicks like like you know like last week
why are we like why why is it you know
but it don't matter like to me it don't
matter and I told her I said look the
rules should just be just be cute just
be cute that's all that's all that
matter to me cute lives matter
have you ever dated a Jewish girl
yeah I did really yeah I did actually
yeah I did actually yeah I did
that [__] this Jewish chick
was like I still in front of her I said
and she was like the best of all time
wow yeah like she was like well made her
the best
I don't know man I feel like I I thought
I thought you know I thought you know
because you [__] I don't know she she
could just do everything she could do
everything she had a nice body like but
you just had a big ass titties and fat
ass and like this she be I don't know
she was licking ass [__] like it was
crazy dog I feel like a little [__]
like I was like yeah like she could do
everything and it was just
oh no I feel like she turned me out I
was still I I stole her moves and be
trying them on me
I mean your ass like I swear to God like
I don't know
maybe it's turned me out anyway she was
the goat I kissed one at 09.
was it 09
our kiss yeah yeah 2009. yeah yeah so
cute yeah
well on that note
Jamar you're forever cute lives matter
and you're forever gonna be our number
one instagram horny boy
and we thank you so much for being here
and we love you thank you and for having
me thank you oh yeah yeah and we'll see
you guys next week with a brand new
episode
[Music]